[Música]
miles de personas se manifestaron en
varias ciudades de México en contra de
la Reforma electoral que plantea el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
es la mayor marcha que la oposición
organiza contra el gobierno desde que
fuera formado Hace cuatro años
en Venezuela la contaminación y la
deforestación han puesto en riesgo a la
laguna reina situada a unos 120
kilómetros de Caracas los habitantes del
lugar buscan contrarrestar los efectos
de la acción humana
a una semana del mundial de fútbol en
Qatar cuatro ciclistas argentinos
recorrieron unos Diez mil kilómetros
pedaleando desde Sudáfrica hasta
Qatar Para apoyar a su selección
nacional les contamos la historia
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano José
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión en
México miles de personas se manifestaron
este domingo en la capital y en otras
ciudades del país contra la propuesta de
reforma del sistema electoral promovida
por el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador Esta movilización es la mayor
organizada contra el presidente de
Centro izquierda desde que asumió el
cargo Hace cuatro años los detalles con
amalvenodman una amplia concentración
contra la reforma electoral le
respaldada por el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador miles de
opositores al mandatario salieron a las
calles de la capital mexicana y de otras
ciudades del país para denunciar las
posibles enmiendas a la comisión
electoral el INE sus críticos dicen que
temen que el jefe de estado concentre
todo el poder en sus manos porque
estamos en contra de la propuesta de
reforma electoral que está proponiendo
el partido Morena que quiere destrozar a
la democracia mexicana para llevarnos a
lugares como Venezuela y Cuba entre los
manifestantes se encontraban el ex
presidente de derecha Vicente Fox así
como grandes figuras empresariales del
país el INE no se toca
país Claro que es perceptible y que
claro que lo podemos mejorar pero no con
su reforma autoritaria que nos quiere
quitar a un órgano autónomo el congreso
comenzó la semana pasada a discutir el
plan presentado en abrir por López
Obrador quien durante mucho tiempo ha
criticado a las autoridades electorales
del país acusando las de haber
contribuido a sus derrotas cuando se
presentó a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2006 y 2012 según el mandatario la
reforma permitiría a los ciudadanos
elegir a las autoridades electorales y
reducir la influencia de los intereses
económicos en la política agregó que
reduciría la financiación de los
partidos políticos y limitaría el tiempo
de publicidad todavía muy popular en
México López Obrador fue elegido en 2018
para un único mandato de 6 años que
terminará en 2024
en Venezuela la laguna la reina a 120
kilómetros de la capital Caracas está en
riesgo debido a la contaminación y la
deforestación los habitantes intentan
tomar conciencia del daño y buscan
maneras de contrarrestar el mal que ha
causado el hombre Andrés granadillo nos
cuenta más
una lucha por salvar a la reina
una laguna cerca de Caracas en Venezuela
cuya gran biodiversidad está en peligro
por la deforestación y la contaminación
al saber todo todas las cosas que que
comprende nuestra laguna no sabían
porque de niños fueron criados con una
cultura de que no valió la pena Pues los
mangles aquí en nuestra comunidad eran
como decís madera para para producir
casas piojos Pero entonces lo veían Como
esos nada más ahora los habitantes de
sus Riberas promueve la educación
ambiental con un proyecto de
conservación llamado una corona para la
reina financiado por el programa de las
Naciones Unidas para el desarrollo
una ong ecobrión lucha entre otros temas
para que no se construya un puente más
elevado que daría paso en la laguna a
embarcaciones de mayor calado tiene que
ver con el tema de la construcción de
carreteras y vías por los espacios de la
laguna las viviendas multifamiliares o
complejos urbanísticos la disposición en
adecuada desechos sólidos la laguna de
120 hectáreas está conectada a la playa
Valle seco cuya línea costera ha
retrocedido al menos 30 metros en la
última década debido al cambio climático
la alcaldía declaró en 2009 este lugar
monumento natural pero a pesar de los
esfuerzos sus orillas son usadas como
vertederos de basura los activistas
buscan que tanto sus habitantes como los
que visitan el lugar tengan conciencia
de su entorno y le devuelvan el reino
que le pertenece a la laguna
en Cuba se cumplen 40 días desde que el
huracán y han golpeado a la isla dejando
importantes daños materiales los mismos
días es que algunos habitantes de la
provincia occidental de Pinar del Río
llevan sin electricidad luego de la
caída de la red eléctrica el gobierno
reconoce que será difícil en el corto
plazo hacerse con los materiales que
permitan reconstruir por completo las
infraestructuras y viviendas destruidas
por el huracán
en Estados Unidos el control de la
cámara de representantes todavía no está
decidido si la cámara baja termina
dirigida por los republicanos eso
implicaría que el actual presidenta de
este órgano legislativo la demócrata
Nancy pelosi sería reemplazada en el
cargo pero si la que fue la mujer más
poderosa de Washington antes de la
llegada de kamala Harris a la
vicepresidencia podría perder el cargo
que ha ostentado hasta ahora repasamos
su perfil con el siguiente informe de
Andrés granadillo
una demócrata que desata amores y odios
Nancy pelosi la hasta ahora presidenta
de la cámara de representantes ha sido
pieza clave en las iniciativas de los
dirigentes de su partido
es un día feliz para nuestro país porque
Joe biden es un unificador porque está
decidido a unir a la gente
ejerció como líder de la cámara
inicialmente de 2007 a 2011 en 2010
ayudó a aprobar el famoso plan de salud
de Obama conocido como Obama Care en
2019 cuando volvió a liderazgo de la
cámara fue fundamental en los planes de
ayuda económica para los estadounidenses
afectados por la pandemia de Kobe 19 y
decisiva en los proyectos de Joe biden
Pero ha sido una piedra en el zapato
para su principal opositor el
expresidente Donald Trump a quien le
inició dos juicios políticos con el
ánimo de destituirlo el primero en 2019
por acusaciones de retención indebida de
ayuda militar a Ucrania y otro en 2021
por incitar el ataque del 6 de enero en
el Capitolio
hoy se produce un vergonzoso salto a
nuestra democracia sin embargo no puede
isodirnos de nuestra responsabilidad de
validar la elección de Joe biden
también ha sido fuerte en la política
exterior en agosto de este año enfureció
a China tras visitar la diputada isla de
Taiwán ser la cara más reconocida de la
cámara de representantes le ha causado
también problemas de seguridad en el
ataque al Capitolio la masa irrumpió en
su oficina mientras gritaba queremos a
Nancy Asimismo el 28 de octubre en su
casa en San Francisco un hombre atacó
brutalmente a su esposo con un martillo
mientras decía donde esta Nancy la
presidenta podría perder su cargo cuando
se defina quién será la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes cuatro
ciclistas argentinos recorrieron unos
Diez mil kilómetros pedaleando desde
Sudáfrica hasta Qatar Para apoyar a su
selección nacional en el mundial de
fútbol que comienza en una semana el
grupo de amigos utilizó sus redes
sociales para narrar el recorrido nos lo
cuenta Andrés triviño
la locura mundialista Ya está presente
en Qatar un grupo de cuatro amigos
argentinos aventuró a recorrer 10.000
kilómetros desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
todo con un solo objetivo apoyar a su
selección doblemente mundialista
[Música]
el Cuarteto argentino realizó un
recorrido de 177 días pedaleando casi
unos seis meses hasta llegar a un
desafío mayor fue el último que fue
cruzar el desierto de Arabia Saudita
tengo que hacer 2000 kilómetros
hicimos más o menos 150 kilómetros por
día y era levantarse comer algo y
desayunar salía de rutas además de
realizar este arduo recorrido el equipo
de toda pedal buscaba romper los
estereotipos sobre las personas de los
países por los que pasaban mientras
grababan imágenes para realizar un
documental Este es el último de una
serie de viajes de larga distancia que
los ciclistas han realizado para asistir
a importantes eventos deportivos como
los Juegos Olímpicos de Río 2016 y el
mundial de Rusia 2018 una aventura
increíble más que una aventura fue una
una escuela de vida pues impresionante
todas las cosas que hemos vivido todavía
no no procesamos no nos damos cuenta no
dimensionamos de de lo que hemos logrado
el equipo utilizó las redes sociales
para narrar su recorrido diario y pedir
ayudas a sus seguidores al llegar a doha
cientos de aficionados los esperaban
para animar su último tramo mientras el
comité de organización y legado de la
FIFA les daba la bienvenida después de
recorrer 10.000 kilómetros en bicicleta
cruzando África y medio oriente los
argentinos de todo a pedal llegaron a
Qatar Para apoyar a su elección en la
copa del mundo ahora el equipo de
ciclista se prepara para ver el debut de
su selección contra Arabia Saudita el 22
de noviembre en luz hay el Stadium
sigan conectados a Francia 24
[Música]